>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SMART
ASKED FOR $25 BILLION TO
BUILD THE BORDER WALL.
CONGRESS GAVE HIM
$1.6 BILLION AND SOME OF IT
FOR FENCING.
BORDER PATROL AGENTS TELL US
THAT THEY'RE LIVED OVER THAT
BUT THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA IS
SAYING JUST THE OPPOSITE.
A "NEW YORK TIMES" HEADLINE
YESTERDAY DECLARED WHAT
BORDER AGENTS SAY THEY WANT
IT'S NOT A WALL.
THE "TIMES" CITED A SURVEY
PUT OUT BY SENATE DEMOCRATS
THAT CLAIMED BORDER AGENTS
REALLY JUST WANT MORE
TECHNOLOGY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SAYS DEMOCRATS GOT
IT ALL WRONG LET'S GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THIS WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE NATIONAL
BORDER PATROL COUNSEL
BRANDON JUDD AND LAREDO,
TEXAS REPRESENTATIVE OF THAT
COUNCIL BORDER PATROL AGENT
HECTOR GARZA.
GOOD TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
BRANDON, LET ME START WITH
YOU.
SAW THIS AND I HAVE KNOWN
YOU GUYS FOR SO LONG.
I HAVE BEEN FRIENDS WITH SO
MANY ON THE BORDER PATROL IN
1996 WHEN I FIRST STARTED IN
THE MEDIA.
WHEN I FIRST SAW THIS I
THOUGHT THIS DOESN'T EACH
PASS THE STRAIGHT FACE TEST
IN ANY WAY, SHAPE OR FORM.
YOUR REACTION.
>> THAT DEMOCRAT STAFF
REPORT IS NOTHING MORE THAN
GARBAGE.
IT MAKES ME SICK KNOWING
THAT THE TAXPAYERS FUNDED A
REPORT THEN IS NOTHING MORE
THAN A PARTISAN HIT PIECE ON
A PRESIDENT WHOM THEY HATE
AND WANT TO SEE FAIL.
WE CAN'T ALLOW THE DEMOCRATS
TO LIE TO THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
SENATOR JOHNSON NEEDS TO
CALL FOR A HEARING ON THIS
ISSUE.
IT NEEDS TO GO BEFORE THE
SENATE ETHICS COMMITTEE.
AND WE HAVE GOT TO
INVESTIGATE THIS AND GET TO
THE BOTTOM.
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU I
JUST FINISHED MY SHIFT A
COUPLE HOURS AGO PATROLLING
THE BORDER.
I SPEAK WITH HUNDREDS OF
AGENTS ON A DAILY BASIS.
AND ALL OF THOSE AGENTS ARE
TELLING ME WE NEED WALLS IN
STRATEGIC LOCATIONS AND WE
WILL PROVE WE NEED THOSE
WALLS.
>> Laura: HECTOR, HERE IS
WHAT THE DEMOCRAT STUDY
SAYS.
WE HAVE A FULL SCREEN WE
WILL PUT UP.
BORDER AGENT SECTOR CHIEFS
RARELY REQUESTED A WALL.
ONLY ONE URGENT AND
COMPELLING REQUEST MENTIONED
EITHER A WALL OR FENCING.
MOST COMMONLY IDENTIFIED
VULNERABILITIES CALL FOR
TECH PERSONNEL.
IN YOUR EXPERIENCE, HECTOR,
WITH EVERYTHING YOU GUYS
RUPP AGAINST, DOES THAT RING
TRUE?
>> NONE AT ALL, LAURA.
I WORK IN THE LAREDO SECTOR.
IN THE LAREDO SECTOR WE DO
NOT HAVE A SINGLE MILE OF
BORDER WALL OR PHYSICAL
BARRIER.
LAREDO SECTOR IS NEXT TO THE
RIO GRAND VALLEY SECTOR
BIGGEST SEQ. FOR FOR DRUG
CROSSINGS AND PEOPLE COMING
OVER ILLEGALLY.
WE CALL FOR WALL IN THE
LAREDO SECTOR BECAUSE JUST
IN THE SECTOR ACROSS THE
BORDER WE HAVE THE DANGEROUS
DRUG CARTEL.
THEY ARE VERY DANGEROUS.
THEY BRING A LOT OF DRUGS
INTO OUR COUNTRY AND ALSO
SMUGGLE A LOT OF PEOPLE INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
WE DEFINITELY NEED A
PHYSICAL BARRIER THAT WILL
SAVE AMERICAN LIVES.
>> Laura: I GUYS MIGHT HAVE
HERD THE SEGMENT WE JUST DID
ON THIS BUDGET THAT JUST
PASSED.
THERE IS NO MONEY FOR MORE
DETENTION BEDS.
THERE IS NO MONEY FOR THAT
BIG BEAUTIFUL CONCRETE WALL
THAT WE HAD HEARD ABOUT FOR
SO LONG.
THE PRESIDENT WANTED
1.6 BILLION JUST FOR THE
WALL.
THERE IS LIKE 640 MILLION
FOR A VARIETY OF THINGS AND
MAYBE 33 MILES OR --
DIFFERENT REPORTS.
I THINK IT'S 33 MILES FOR
REINFORCED DOUBLE FENCING
AND SOME LEVEE WALLS THAT
ARE ALREADY THERE.
BUT THIS IS NO NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
BRANDON, I'M HEARING YOU
GUYS.
YOU GUYS ARE ON THE FRONT
LINE, THE CARTELS ARE
COMING.
WE HAVE THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
PEOPLE JUST TRYING TO CROSS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO WORK
HERE.
OTHERS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEIR MOTIVES ARE WE ARE
LIKE WELL, WE WILL HAVE SOME
SENSORS AND SOME ROADS AND
MAYBE WE HAVE SOME MORE
DETENTION FACILITIES.
>> THE REPUBLICANS ARE
SHOOTING THEMSELVES IN THE
FOOT.
THE PRESIDENT RAN ON A
CAMPAIGN OF DOMESTIC
POLICIES THAT WERE GOING TO
SECURE THE AMERICAN
INTERESTS WHICH AND ONE OF
THOSE WAS THE BORDER.
THE REPUBLICANS AREN'T DOING
WHAT THE CONSTITUENCY WANTS
THEM TO DO.
AND IF THEY DON'T JUMP ON
BOARD AND IF THEY DON'T GET
BEHIND THIS PRESIDENT.
IF THEY DON'T SECURE THE
BORDER, THEY STAND TO LOSE
HUGE IN THE MID TERMS.
>> Laura: I AGREE.
>> WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE THE
REPUBLICANS GET BEHIND THIS
PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE GOT TO GET RID OF
THE SWAMP.
THAT INCLUDES THE WATCH
WITHIN OUR OWN AGENCY IF
WE'RE GOING TO EXPECT TO
HOLD THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE IN 2018.
>> Laura: HECTOR, THIS IS
WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
TODAY.
AGAIN, HE DIDN'T LIKE THE
FACT HE HAD TO SIGN THIS BUT
DID HE GO AHEAD AND SIGN IT
LET'S LISTEN.
>> WE ARE GOING TO BE
STARTING WORK LITERALLY ON
MONDAY ON NOT ONLY SOME NEW
WALL, NOT ENOUGH, BUT WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT VERY
QUICKLY.
BUT ALSO FIXING EXISTING
WALLS AND EXISTING
ACCEPTABLE FENCES.
THERE ARE SOME AREAS THAT
YOU HAVE TO SEE THROUGH.
HAVE YOU TO BE ABLE TO SEE
THROUGH THE OTHER SIDE IN
ORDER TO SEE WHAT'S COMING.
AND IN MANY CASES IT'S NOT A
PRETTY PICTURE.
>> Laura: OH MY GOD.
OKAY.
NUMBER ONE, HECTOR, JUST
EXPLAIN THE PART THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE SEE THROUGH
WALL.
I UNDERSTAND WE DO NEED TO
SEE KIND OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
ON THE OTHER SIDE.
BUT, I DON'T THINK THERE IS
GOING TO BE ANY PHYSICAL
WALL BEING BUILT BECAUSE
THERE IS NO MONEY FOR THE
WALL.
IT'S ALL REPAIRING THE
FENCING THAT EXISTS AND THE
LEVEE WALLS THAT ARE ALREADY
THERE AND SOME OF THEM
CRUMBLING.
BUT, CAN YOU -- CAN YOU SHED
ANY LIGHT ON THAT FOR ME?
BECAUSE I HAVE GOT TO
FRANKLY BUY A VOWEL.
I DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND
IT.
>> IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE
THAT WE CAN'T GET A BORDER
WALL, A MUCH NEEDED WALL
THAT WE NEED SO WE CAN DO
OUR JOB.
THAT WALL IS GOING TO SAVE
AMERICAN LIVES.
IT'S JUST VERY UNFORTUNATE
THAT SOME OF THESE
REPRESENTATIVES ARE ACTUALLY
PLAYING GAMES WITH OUR JOBS
AND WITH OUR SECURITY.
WE NEED TO STOP PLAYING
POLITICS AND WE NEED THIS
WALL.
IT'S NO SECRET OUR BORDER
PATROL AGENTS HAVE ACTUALLY
REACHED OUT TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP THROUGH THE NATIONAL
BORDER PATROL COUNSEL AND WE
TOLD THEM WE WANTED A WALL.
THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE THE
SAME THING.
HE HAS SPOKEN TO OUR AGENTS
DIRECTLY.
THE AGENTS HAVE TOLD HIM
PRESIDENT TRUMP WE NEED A
WALL TO SECURE THE BORDER.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED SO WE
CAN DO OUR JOB AND SO WE CAN
SAVE THOSE AMERICAN LIVES
AND STOP THOSE DRUGS FROM
COMING ACROSS.
>> Laura: BRANDON, I HAVE TO
READ TO YOU AND YOU ARE
GOING TO LOVE THIS SENATOR
CLAIR MCCASKILL.
I KNOW YOU ARE TEXTING
BUDDIES.
SHE IS ON THE HOMELAND
COMMITTEE.
THIS REPORT CONFIRMS WHAT I
HAVE HEARD FROM FRONT LINE
BORDER AGENTS AND CBP
LEADERS ALIKE THAT THE TOP
PRIORITIES ARE ADDRESSING
THE VULNERABILITIES ALONG
OUR BORDER AND ADDITIONAL
PERSONNEL AND TECHNOLOGY.
WE CAN'T PROTECT OUR
COUNTRY.
SHE SAID THAT ALSO PAUL RYAN
HAS BEEN VERY CHIPPER ABOUT
THE IDEA OF ALL THESE SENEL
SORES AND THE DRONES AND THE
OTHER THINGS NECESSARY TO
ENFORCE THE BORDER.
WHAT I UNDERSTAND FROM
ISRAEL AND WHAT I UNDERSTAND
FROM YOU IN ALL THE YEARS I
HAVE KNOWN YOU, WITHOUT THAT
BARRIER, IT MAKES YOUR LIFE
MORE DIFFICULT AT EVERY TURN
AND HECTOR, I ASSUME YOU
WOULD AGREE BUT BRANDON, YOU
FIRST.
>> LAURA, WE HAVE PLAYED
THAT GAME.
WE HAVE THROWN ALL KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGY AT DRONES AT
SENSORS.
IT'S INTERESTING THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC REPORT QUOTES
FORMER DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
DAVID AGUILAR.
HE NOW SITS ON THE BOARD OF
DRONE AVIATION CORPS
INDUSTRY.
OBVIOUSLY YOU DON'T WANT A
WALL.
IF YOU GET THE WALL YOU
AREN'T GOING TO BE SELLING
DRONES.
IF PEOPLE AREN'T CROSSING
THE BORDER ILLEGALLY NO NEED
TO BUY DRONES.
WE HAVE ALREADY DONE THAT WE
DON'T NEED TO DO IT AGAIN.
WE NEED TO BUILD OUT
PHYSICAL BARRIERS THAT ARE
NECESSARY U.
>> Laura: THINK ABOUT THIS
HECTOR AND BRANDON HAVE YOU
THE SENSOR COMPANIES AND THE
DRONE COMPANIES.
EVERYBODY IS LOOKING FOR A
PIECE OF THE PIE, RIGHT?
ALL THE MONEY THAT'S GOING
TO BE INVESTED BUT IF IT'S
JUST OUT WALL AND THE EXTRA
PERSONNEL AND SO FORTH, IT'S
A LOT SIMPLER.
IT'S A LOT SIMPLER.
GUYS, GOD BLESS YOU FOR THE
WORK YOU DO.
KEEP IT UP AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND I KNOW SO MANY OF
OUR VIEWERS AT FOX AND ON